Speaker 1: Here's just a wild, wild report from
Vanity Fair's Bess Levin. Donald Trump thought he
could sue Congress for impeaching him. He thought
he could sue Congress because as legislators, they
impeached him. Now, what's not clear is whether he
thought he could sue Congress as an institution or
that he could sue the individual members who
voted to impeach and later in the Senate to
convict. With Trump, it's never really clear what
he means. This entire article is worth reading
by Bess Levin, and the key part is actually from
Maggie Haberman, forthcoming book Confidence Man,
which says When the House introduced articles
of impeachment against Trump for the first time
in 2019, Trump reacted with a familiar refrain.
According to the book, I'll just sue Congress.
They can't do this to me. Bess Levin adds It's not
clear whether Trump responded similarly after the
second impeachment articles, though, there's
probably a 50% chance that he did listen. This
would not really be a shock to anybody who's been
following the I guess we would call them trials
and tribulations of Trump. He thought that pulling
in a special master after the Mar a Lago search
warrant was going to be good for him. And it did
not work out that way. He looked directly into the
sun during that eclipse, even though he was told
not to. I mean, at the micro level and the macro
level, he always believes things that aren't true
and believe certain things would be good for him
that actually are not. What's particularly funny
about Trump thinking he can sue Congress is that
right now we talked about this yesterday on the
bonus show. The argument that Trump's lawyers
are making to get a defamation suit against Trump
dismissed is that the defendant should actually be
the government and not Trump. And so you have this
extraordinary situation where on and the point is
you can't sue the government for defamation. So
it's defamation versus the impeachment. But on the
one hand, in court, Trump's lawyers are arguing
you can't go after the government for defamation.
And really, Eugene Carroll's gripe is with the
government and not with Trump, even though it
was Trump who said the things that are allegedly
defamatory. And meanwhile, after and during the
impeachment, Trump was saying, Well, I'll just
sue the government as if that's something you
can do over a legislative duty that Congress has,
which is to consider whether a president has done
something worthy of impeachment. It's all it's
all completely scrambled. You all know that. And
the other theme to this is the things that are
said publicly in the court of public opinion by
Trump and even sometimes by his lawyers don't
translate to what they actually try to argue
in court. These are two different things. And
likewise, nobody's going to sue Congress for
carrying out an impeachment. And of course,
it didn't happen. We will see what ultimately
comes of 2024. But Bess Levin sort of raising
the alarm here and saying, listen, the election
stuff was not the only wacky, dangerous, unhinged
stuff that Donald Trump was thinking at that time.